[Música]
é botar todos em primeiro lugar é
criança solar e e unir aí que eu não
existe algo que é muito apoio e não de
uma forma comum como a autodeterminação
estados basicamente na personalidade de
cada um de nós de fazer as suas próprias
escolhas branca vida e tomar as suas
próprias decisões mas em primeiro lugar
para você conseguir situar pra mim
tomando turística todo meu discurso vai
pautar por uma idéia muito simples eu
acredite o convite tamento podendo se
assim desejamos ter um papel ativo na
construção de uma sociedade mais justa e
que promova a igualdade de oportunidades
para todas as pessoas sem qualquer tipo
de xexéu iniciam todos os dias ficar
cada vez mais perto da competição
prática neste mundial já foram traçados
corridos grande mas infelizmente ainda
estamos aquém do desejável o que
significa que ainda grandes traços e
três para criar e para o corrente verão
particularmente alguns caracterizam por
por ser uma minoria silenciosa
silenciosa e silenciado
este grupo integra as pessoas com
deficiência que eu esqueça a companhia
em portugal todas estas pessoas de foco
individualizado de travar uma luta
constante para manter um diamante silva
que todos nós pertence à nossa dignidade
mas como é que poderemos hoje todos nós
enfrentaríamos ainda com um certo que
todos tiraram a maioria das pessoas o
seu lento com o seu projeto
fila no nosso caso uma sociedade que os
exclui em infinita e eu aprendi muitos
nós não conseguimos melhor autonomia
livremente pelas ruas que não existe
conhecer pra isso muitos nós não
conseguem ter acesso por força de
impossibilidade econômica só por falta
em outro contexto é produtos técnicos
que são imprescindíveis para a sua
autonomia e sua qualidade de vida
muitos nós não você não tão simples como
apanhar um transporte público ou a ser
um serviço como a segurança social as
finanças e ainda é possível tudo isto
antes nós estamos absolutamente
dependente das pessoas famílias todos os
dias sendo retirada a possibilidade sim
é muito menos concretizar como uma final
torna e independente nos moldes que
todos os opcionais como ter um emprego
uma casa ou conseguir um família espécie
essencialmente um estado social que não
ganhou até um anjo respostas que
tivessem como foco efetivamente a
promoção da autonomia e da independência
ea escolha em particular as mães vêem se
muitas vezes obrigadas a colocar as suas
vidas e indicados por toda uma vida
ainda mais este cenário
estudos mostram que a maioria vive com
rendimentos que se tornou na pobreza
mesmo que os que se encontram integrados
no mercado de trabalho e na vida por
aquilo que ela tem mais duas
possibilidades estamos vivos
o texto propõe que os coloquei um outro
prisma resolviam de uma forma simples e
construtiva e consensual que ciência nos
diz e em simultâneo dar um solução
através de um peão a consciência
coletiva porque a nossa utilizada ser
nosso direito à autodeterminação e
portanto mas nós fazemos nossas escolhas
de qualquer um de nós está dependendo
das finais em que estamos 20 nos também
é preciso atentar para o fato que todos
nós em geral temos uma potência menor
para nos focar os seus problemas que nos
afetam direta e individualmente uma
escala mais mícron empenhados nos uns
anos nossos próprios problemas e sim
conjuntos realizados longe
esta tendência não é necessário nem
consta de decisão pois temos dela quem
sai e que de uma forma de 200 nos
esforcemos para alargar o nosso andar
acredito que todas as pessoas são
acusadas de uma incrível capacidade de
superação é o final que o senhor teria
vida que se não fossem os desafios de
colocar todos os dias
o desafio de como os jovens todos os
praticantes de pensarmos e de criar
novas funções
considere podemos olhar para nós e para
os outros
isto pode parecer um certo corintiana já
que a gente mesmo tempo importante
pensarmos sobre isto
eu tenho uma convicção muito forte na
vida acredito que todos nós prevemos a
nossa vida como escreve um livro com
quem conta uma história somos nós
próprios autores ea personagem principal
mas sempre com a contribuição daqueles
que nos rodeiam os outros personagens
que determinam vários momentos da nossa
história
mas nesse processo prevaleceu aquela
sensação deliciosa de que somos nós o
personagem principal
esta convicção sem muitas vezes de
aumento em inúmeras situações como
programa certamente presidente hugo
chávez nem todas as pessoas podem
escrever seu livro o filme particular
aquelas que não
nova fase da sua vida ou precocemente se
viram confrontados com a circunstância
de ficar com o seu corpo e usava ou
incapacitado tal como eu
esses incapacidades podem ser físicas
sensoriais ou psicossociais encontra-se
alimento nos livros nos estudos nos
quadros nos plantios nos cursos das
entidades que nos representou menos nós
próprios discurso encontrou os
portadores de deficiências em foco pela
manhã tinha gente em quem votar para as
inscrições com que nos defrontamos ao
longo de nossas vidas
dia após dia nos anti estaria aqui
propor durante 16 dias em frente ao
invés de permanecer no campo do que está
errado
vamos primeiro olhar forma cuidadosa e
crítica preto já foi conquistado nas
últimas décadas
a par disto mesmo manter o foco dos
problemas vamos propor soluções e
refletir sobre possibilidades de
inclusão para exercício de consciência
consegue somente que são necessárias
duas coisas primeiro uma capacidade de
reflexão sobre as próprias e tudo aquilo
que nos banha e segundo levantar pra
aceitar um desafio como sabe algum nova
pensar em uma realidade que para muitos
é desconhecida ou pouco família podem
ter algumas funções dela mas só com a
proximidade com o confronto mais ou
menos directos é que poderão conseguir
nos sonhos concretas deste mundo
exterior não têm formas conversa não tem
isso não significa nem fazer por maior
que sejam os seis com tudo pra não
precisar isto é preciso partir do
princípio que este é um problema
coletivo e não individual
criar e algumas pessoas com deficiência
suas famílias as instituições que
representam as duas próximas os diversos
contextos em que se encontram inseridas
pro melhor coesão social e política
todos nós em conjunto e confinar poder
contribuir para atenuar alguns dos
efeitos negativos desses problemas
através da proposta as funções e
capacidades da selecção
estas propostas vão sempre basear se no
princípio de conferir dignidade e valor
às pessoas e não numa perspectiva
carregado o assistencialismo mas pra
isso acho importante assumir que ele vai
fazer um show com os rodeia tal como
disse
entretanto criadas a capacidade de
colocar no total do outro
é preciso torcer e não ter medo da
mudança e em conjunto contra luis chutar
forte por um objetivo com um exemplo
quando eu entrei para a universidade do
porto não existiam algumas condições
fundamentais para que eu pudesse
usufruir do meu percurso académico e foi
pela capacidade de reflexão das pessoas
responsáveis e do seu poder para decidir
a mudança foram criadas novas condições
pra mim e pra outros estudantes que elas
incitassem com este esforço coletivo da
nossa universidade
mesmo quando este onde vierem
inteiramente seu mestrado porto
tornou-se claramente um exemplo de boas
práticas no entanto diz permitam forçar
que ajuda a reduzir em 30 o estado está
se ao para a criação das duas novas
respostas e quando nem com as suas
respectivas responsabilidades e parecem
da universidade do porto por aqui tem um
papel muito importante de uma situação
gerada sociedade que já tem feito aqui
convosco
ele sabe um crédito individual um querer
fazer um creditar uma vontade inabalável
do crer conseguir isso é transversal a
todos os objetos vida independentemente
da existência de deficiências porque
quanto à sua capacidade propriamente
ditas qualquer um nosso pronto de alguma
com elas ou por sermos um papel por
razões de doença enfim algumas situações
e mesmo nesse momento não deixando de
ser quem somos e não deixa me querer
lutar por aquilo em que acreditamos nos
parece crescer também depois deste
esforço coletivo na procura de respostas
grande todos alguns homens também não
somos tão diferentes como inicialmente
se poderia pensar só somos pessoas
cremos
fazer escolhas porque como nos diz onde
eu hein
por ser estreita cedo e num clubinho nem
do pesado a mão que muitos toma
eu sou dono e senhor do meu destino eu
sou uma anta em alma
por isso quando eles a todos a
possibilidade de escrever e foliar o seu
próprio livro
descobriremos com um sorriso foi um dos
co autor dos livros dos outros e que o
que está no campo pelo iso é somente uma
pessoa deixa uma sugestão como
instrumento 8 às críticas das histórias
que não só por serem irmãos e em
simultâneo autor e co-autor informar os
próximos responsáveis e eficientes
capazes de provocar mudança social
gradualmente
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]